méxico país que junto a argentina es el
de mayor producción fílmica de
latinoamerica la pandemia deja un sector
extenuado tras más de 4 meses de cierre
obligado de salas la cámara nacional de
la industria cinematográfica estima que
se han dejado de vender 152 millones de
boletos lo que equivale a una pérdida de
más de 330 millones de dólares para
poder reabrir los cines han tenido que
aplicar estrictos protocolos de higiene
y reducir su aforo nuestras salas están
adaptadas a una capacidad del 30 por
ciento del aforo total del complejo
aplicar estas medidas sanitarias ha
tenido un alto costo todos los insumos y
los parados no se están encareciendo la
propia operación y nos tuvimos que
financiar para poder eso para poder
llevar esto y para poder abrir y para
volver a filmar las casas productoras
también debieron pagar el costo de los
protocolos sanitarios sumado a las
pérdidas que ya tenían tras un rodaje
detenido más de cuatro meses la cineasta
paula astorga tuvo que cambiar el set de
trigal el filme que actualmente produce
ahí perdimos mucho dinero porque había
cosas que se había
para que te amo digamos y que en el
momento de regresar a filmar que ya no
tenemos las condiciones porque no hay
aeropuertos para regresar a filmar tan
lejos tuvimos que cambiar a una locación
aquí en el estado de puebla además del
embate del cob y de la industria
cinematográfica enfrenta la amenaza de
perder los apoyos gubernamentales
producto de la autoridad aplicada en la
administración de andrés manuel lópez
obrador la idea generó una inconformidad
liderada por figuras como el director
guillermo del toro y el actor gael
garcía que han buscado convencer al
congreso de la importancia de mantener
los fondos públicos y todo este apoyo
nos haría muy competitivos en un mercado
que está dañado por la falta de
protección primicia que sucedió en el
tratado de comercio queremos que el
apoyo principal de estos fondos creo
es para los nuevos realizadores de todas
las partes de méxico para la gente menos
favorecida la iniciativa se frenó pero
la intención persiste y mientras la
industria del cine lucha por sobrevivir
resurgen algunas tradiciones que se
adaptan a las circunstancias como los
autocinemas así las audiencias también
se han tenido que ajustar a los nuevos
tiempos